- What else should I say?
(Both laughs)
(thrilling music)
We've been dating for
eight and a half years.
Honestly, I'm the one who
does most of the cooking.
I would say that I am the better cook,
but actually George is a great cook
- Before Jasmine, I did cook a lot.
When I was living on my own,
I would cook pretty much every night,
and I do really enjoy cooking.
- He doesn't really measure things
but it's still really delicious.
- That's what makes me a good cook.
- Oh, that's what makes
me a good cook too.
- Yeah. Go team.
- Go team.
I think it's gonna be so easy
to guess what George made.
- [Producer] If you don't get it right,
let's add some stakes to this.
- Sushi for a week. (inhales deeply)
- That's good, for you.
- Good luck babe.
- All right. Oh, whoa!
- So to make the competition more fair,
I've chosen three ingredients
that each chef must use,
which are udon, kimchi, and butter.
Because these three
ingredients already make up
a very simple recipe
that I actually enjoy,
I also feel like it puts a parameter
around what they can make.
George has some pretty tough competition.
First, there's Katie,
who I cook with often.
I've eaten a lot of the dishes she's made,
not a single one that I don't like.
Mimo, she comes from an
extraordinary pastry background.
Her dishes are bound to look flawless.
George has worked with these
ingredients very, very often.
I really expect him to
hit it out of the park.
(upbeat ethereal music)
- Today I'm making Jasmine a
Kimchi Udon Noodle Stir Fry.
Let's go ahead and begin.
So I'm starting with a
little bit of olive oil
'cause I'm gonna fry some garlic.
So wait for that to get to temperature.
I'm just gonna add in my garlic now.
And I'm just gonna lightly,
not even brown them.
Jasmine and I are both huge garlic lovers.
Now that the garlic is
pretty much transparent.
I'm just gonna add in this kimchi,
and I'm using tong so
that I'm only governing
the kimchi itself, and I'm
saving the juice for later.
So I know Jasmine love kimchi
and she loves a lot of it.
So now I'm going to add
in a little bit more oil,
and my beef brisket.
I chose beef brisket for this dish
because I wanted to add a
little bit of meat to it.
And I personally love beef briskets.
I'm a little bit concerned
that I'm gonna make a
Frankenstein dish for Jasmine
because she grew up eating
Korean food, I didn't.
In a way, I don't want to take it too far
from what she's used to,
but I do want to kind of give
it my own natural splash.
So the beef is a little bit pink now
which means it's time to
move on to the next stage.
Now I'm adding in the corn.
I don't know if this is a very
traditional Korean recipe,
but it just adds that really
great balance to the dish
'cause it adds a sweetness to it.
I and Jasmine loves corn.
So now that we've got the
three main ingredients
all ready and cooked up,
we're just gonna add
in the wet ingredients.
So that's gonna be my Kewpie mayo here.
The Kewpie mayo is a little bit different
from just regular Mayo.
It's a Japanese mayonnaise,
which means it's a little bit sweeter.
It's a little bit tarter.
Next thing I'm gonna add is the gochujang
is a Korean chili paste.
It's really delicious.
I'm also gonna be adding this butter.
I'm not gonna use the entire thing.
She doesn't really love butter.
And then the last of the wet ingredients
is gonna be the leftover kimchi juice.
So this is what we saved earlier.
I'm just gonna give
this a nice little stir.
Now I got a pack of the
frozen udon noodles.
And the udon noodles are
actually already cooked.
So you don't need to
necessarily cook them.
But what I like to do is
I like to just dunk 'em
in a bowl of water,
and that way the noodles
are gonna separate.
We're just gonna let the udon
noodles cook for a little bit.
And once they're ready,
I'm gonna give this a little bit of a try.
(thrilling music)
Definitely need of these
a good bit more gochujang,
but I think after this, it should be good.
I'm not sure if I'm gonna win this guys.
So right now I'm adding
some crushed black pepper
'cause I feel like the
dish needed a little bit
of that spice that wasn't
coming from the gochujang.
Taste test number two.
(thrilling music)
Oh, yes!
So next up,
we're gonna add in this
shredded mozzarella cheese.
And this is more of a
new Korean ingredient.
I don't think that mozzarella cheese
is necessarily very traditional either.
While I'm waiting for this
mozzarella cheese to melt,
I'm just gonna add in this slice scallion
to give it that nice little pop of color.
This is coming along nicely.
The cheese is starting
to get nice and melty.
Now the tricky part is
gonna be when I played it,
'cause I am an awful plater.
All right, here comes plating time baby.
I got this.
Oh my god, my mom raised a winner.
No, she you've raised the loser.
Mom, you still love me, right?
Some finishing touches
with little bit more cheese
just on top 'cause I kind
of flipped everything
up side down.
A little bit more scallion.
And lastly, this is very optional.
I'm just adding in a little
bit of toasted sesame seeds.
And that is my dish.
(upbeat ethereal music)
- Today I'm making Udon Gyoza.
I think that Jasmine might know
that I'm attracted to this.
It looks fun to make.
So she might know it's me.
I'm gonna put all of my sauces
and seasoning together first.
So that is some sesame oil.
We've got our oyster sauce here,
which is something Jasmine uses a lot.
I'm gonna do some soy sauce.
Some garlic.
Jasmine loves garlic.
And then I've got some
ginger and some salt.
I'm just eyeballing that.
And this is potato starch,
which is just gonna act
like keep it all together.
I found a bunch of recipes
on Japanese websites
and I found one on "Bon Appetit."
I'm putting my own twist on it,
so we'll see how it turns out.
I'm gonna give this a taste
just to see if I got the flavor right.
(thrilling music)
A lot of potato starch.
I feel like this was
lacking in ginger flavor,
and I think I could do even
a little bit more garlic.
So I'm gonna do pork.
This is kind of based off a pork gyoza
that she made for our tasty time to cook,
go check out that video.
And then I'm adding some green onions.
And now I'm adding the kimchi.
And I'm gonna eyeball this.
And now we have our udon noodles.
So that's two out of
the three ingredients.
We're making the filling
of what would be in gyoza.
And then the udon noodles
are kind of acting like the wrapper.
And then last thing we're
gonna do is add an egg.
I think she's gonna like this.
I'm also sorry to anyone
who's made this before,
I'm not doing it right.
All right, I think this is looking good.
I hope tastes good.
So I am gonna get kind
of like a golf ball size
in my hand here and make some patties.
All right, my patties are ready.
I'm gonna take a little bit of oil.
What I don't want is
these to be super greasy.
I feel like Jasmine would
be like, "Ting, bad."
We're gonna let that oil heat up.
I think the oil is hot enough.
I'm putting in...
Ooh, yes.
It kinda reminds me of making
like a vegetable fritter
or any kind of like potato fritter.
And I like it to be nice
and thin and crispy.
Looking good.
I'm gonna cover these guys
for five minutes and let them cook.
So chance I turned the heat
up too high on these guys.
Oh, okay.
Great. We got some color.
They're like little burgers.
I'm gonna let this go
for three more minutes.
These guys are done,
so I'm going to put them on my plate.
They're really big.
I think they're a little bigger
than I initially intended.
Okay, I'm gonna move on to my sauce now.
For the sauce,
I'm gonna be making like
a kimchi butter sauce.
Yeah, I don't think that
Jasmine does like butter.
Why did she choose it?
I have some kimchi paste here.
I'm gonna add that in.
I'm gonna turn my heat down
'cause I don't wanna brown the butter.
Jasmine will definitely know it's me
if it has brown butter,
'cause I love brown butter.
and I'm gonna add some soy sauce.
We're gonna add some honey for sweetness.
Now I'm gonna add in the garlic chili oil.
Ooh, salty.
I think I'm gonna add a
little bit more butter,
and I'm gonna do a little
bit more of the kimchi paste
because I feel like it's
bringing in the spice,
and I want a little more spice.
I think that's gonna be good.
I feel like I had 7
outta 10 of confidence.
That's pretty high.
I'm gonna transfer this to my
bowl, and we're almost done.
Oh, it's so cute.
We've got the patties on a plate.
I'm gonna put the sauce in the
middle for our final plating,
and then I'm going scallions.
Just come back and forth,
but I wanted this to look sort of pretty.
I always love like a cracked fresh pepper
on like anything I'm eating,
and if I did that,
Jasmine would like a
thousand percent know.
Did George use black pepper?
She's definitely gonna think that's me.
(upbeat ethereal music)
- Today I'll be making Okonomiyaki.
I know Jasmine pretty well.
We eat lunch together a lot,
so I feel like I know what she likes
and what she doesn't like.
I know George is Jasmine's boyfriend
and he gets like the inside scoop.
As the culinary expert,
I think I know better.
Let's get started.
First, I'm gonna add two eggs to this bowl
and I'm gonna whisk it well.
Then I'm gonna add my chicken stock.
And now I'm gonna add my flour.
I'm gonna add some salt.
And I'm now gonna fold
my other ingredients.
I'm gonna start with my carrots,
and then I'm gonna add the cabbage.
And now I'm gonna add my
udon noodles and my kimchi.
I eat kimchi a lot, and cabbage,
but the other ones, I
don't cook with that often.
Now I'm gonna add some oil to my pan,
and I'm gonna be generous
'cause I don't want it to stick.
And now I'm gonna add some
butter for some flavor in here.
I know Jasmine loves butter,
so she's gonna love that.
Now that that's ready.
We're gonna add our batter.
Make sure it's beautiful,
and cook that until it's
crispy on the bottom,
and then I will flip it.
Honestly speaking, Jasmine
likes a lot of things.
She's very open to trying different foods.
I am like 90% sure she's gonna like this.
So I think it's time to flip
'cause it looks like it's set.
I'm gonna use this plate.
Put it back on there, that
way it cooks beautiful.
Ta-da! (laughs)
I know traditionally,
this dish doesn't have kimchi and udon,
so I just switched up some ingredients
in order to include Jasmine's
favorite ingredients in here.
It smells so good.
If Jasmine doesn't like
this, I'm gonna be very hurt.
First, we're gonna top it
with the okonomiyaki sauce,
and I'm gonna be pretty
generous with this guy.
And then we're gonna
top it with Kewpie mayo.
And then we have a dehydrated pork.
It's a little bit candid,
it gives it a different layer of flavor.
Then we have some furikake.
And then we have some scallions.
And it's all done.
I hope Jasmine likes this.
I will be hurt if she picks
someone else's and not mine.
I think she might have an idea
that this is mine 'cause
she knows I like baking,
and this is sort of like
a pancake, but we'll see.
(playful music)
- Oh my gosh, I'm so excited.
Thank you.
Mmm, I think it's George.
But right off the bat, green onions,
I do it just like this.
I add corn in my stir fried noodles,
and I'm seeing some thinly sliced beef.
It reminds me of Korean barbecue.
He knows I love Korean barbecue.
There's mozzarella cheese.
He knows I love that combination.
(thrilling music)
Mmm, you can't tell me
it's not George. (laughs)
This tastes delicious.
This is pretty much exactly
how I would make mine,
with maybe a little less cream
and a little less cheese.
This is exactly how George would make it.
Ah, yeah. How could it not be him?
Good job babe. Good job.
Thank you so much.
Wow.
That's creative. Wow.
Right off the bat,
I have no clue who made this.
Maybe it's Katie?
(thrilling music)
Mmm, Good job. Very good.
Is it pork in there?
That's very nice.
The noodles are nice and bouncy.
Good crisp.
My gut is telling me Katie.
She developed tasty recipes
for a very long time,
and that requires her to
get really, really creative.
This is a very delicious dish.
I'm very surprised that
with those three ingredients
you were able to conjure
up something like this.
Thank you.
Wow.
Holy moly!
This reminds me of okonomiyaki.
Okay, I gotta try this.
Right off the bat, I think this is Mimo,
because she comes from
a pastry background,
so she's used to making
things look phenomenal.
(thrilling music)
Mmm, it's delightful.
Very good.
I love pork, so I stand
by my final answer.
I think it's you, Mimo.
I think I've gotten three
amazing recipes today
that have been super
creative and out of the box.
I think this one is George's.
(thrilling music)
- Oh.
- You were right baby.
- Oh, I was right.
Yes!
He knows I always complain
about any kimchi dish
not having enough kimchi,
and like, this has a lot of kimchi juice.
And the corn, like that's
very telltale sign.
- I guess I know her best.
- Maybe I know all of you
guys the best. (laughs)
I think this one is Katie's.
Oh.
- Ta-da!
Oh my god, I know you would know.
- I knew.
- I know my friends well. I'm so happy.
Come on out Mimo.
- Ta-da!
- Oh my god.
I think it's really special
because when I'm cooking,
I always try to infuse my personality,
my identity into my foods,
and I feel like I really saw that today.
It was like very much
proven by your dishes.
My favorite, I'm not
gonna lie, it's this one.
- Oh yay.
- Oh, wow.
- Why did you choose butter?
- I love butter.
- Okay?
- Oh, okay.
I said she doesn't like the
flavor of butter. (laughs)
She doesn't really love butter.
- Does that look you know her?
Yeah. I don't that
Jasmine does like butter.
- Free sushi for a week.
- Yeah! Yes!
- [George] Oh, yes!
(bouncy music)